Speaker 1: So we have an opportunity here
to do a little bit of of learning of education
about how our electoral system works and some
of the nuances and particulars that some of
us may not be familiar with.
The story about Mike Pence's possible role
in the 2020 election is again just front and
center, as Donald Trump's new spokeswoman,
Liz Harrington, posted to Twitter.
A statement from Trump going after Mike Pence
saying Pence could have turned over the election
if he wanted and essentially given it to Trump.
The statement put out yesterday from Trump
reads If the Vice President, Mike Pence had
quote, absolutely no right to change the presidential
election results in the Senate despite fraud
and many other irregularities, how come the
Democrats and rhino Republicans like wacky
Susan Collins are desperately trying to pass
legislation that will not allow the vice president
to change the results of the election?
Actually, what they are saying is that Mike
Pence did have the right to change the outcome,
and they now want to take that right away.
Unfortunately, he didn't exercise that power.
He could have overturned the election.
Now.
It's not true that the laws that are being
proposed about the vice president's role are
because the vice president could overturn
the election.
It's almost like there's so many ignorant
people that falsely think the vice president
can just decide who wins that they're looking
at putting something more basic in writing.
To that end, but we actually have an infrastructure
of law already that makes it very clear that
the vice president's role with the Electoral
College is just opening the envelopes literally
and figuratively, and we're going to get to
that.
But think about what they're saying.
I mean, if if what Trump is saying is correct,
it means Kamala Harris could choose the winner
of the 2024 election if she doesn't like who
the person that supposedly won Kamala could
say, nope, somebody else won.
And of course, that's not the case.
The truth is that the vice president does
not have the power to do any of the things
that Donald Trump has hoped that Pence would
have done, including, you know, seating an
alternate slate of electors from certain states
or any such thing.
The 12th Amendment governs this really, really
clearly.
And you can just Google 12th Amendment and
read the entire thing.
It's not very long.
But the the important relevant points here
are that the 12th Amendment says the electors
shall meet in their respective states and
vote by ballot for president and vice president.
They shall name in their ballots the person
voted for as president.
OK, fair.
The president of the Senate, meaning the vice.
Remember, the VP of the U.S. is the president
of the Senate.
The president of the Senate shall in the presence
of the Senate and House, meaning a joint session
open all the certificates and the votes shall
then be counted.
That says nothing about evaluate whether this
is the correct slate of electors.
It's the VP shall open the certificates and
the votes shall then be counted.
Doesn't even say the vice president will be
doing the counting.
The votes shall be counted.
The person having the greatest number of votes
for president shall be the president.
That's it.
You then have, in addition to the 12th Amendment,
the Electoral Count Act of 1887.
Now why in 1887?
Well, in 1876 there was a disputed election
and in the roughly nine, 10 or 11 years that
followed the Electoral Count Act of 1887 was
put together.
It also is very clear it no one puts the onus
of resolving disputes to the states.
If there are disputes, the state resolves
the disputes, not the federal government or
the Congress.
So, for example, if a governor from Arizona
certified two different slates of electors,
they sign off on some Democratic electors
and then a slate of Republican electors.
That would be a real problem.
If a state just doesn't certify any electors,
that would be a problem that would come to
Congress.
But 90 percent of that is states handle these
issues.
Now, if you have one of these extenuating
circumstances where the federal government
gets involved, there's a few things Congress
can do if there is a ministerial error, if
there is an elector sent who's not eligible
to be an elector for some reason.
If there is a candidate certified who isn't
eligible to be president, those would be reasons
why Congress can get involved.
It's very clearly very limited, and to deviate
from that requires powers that the vice president
doesn't have.
It depends on the House and Senate, and that's
where all of this stuff comes from.
A member of the House would stand an object,
and then they need a member of the Senate
to stand and object with them, etc.
So the story that they're telling isn't it's
not only a dangerous story, it's also an untrue
story.
And what we're up against is that in March,
Trump and Pence are both speaking back to
back nights at a Republican committee event
in New New Orleans, Louisiana, and it'll be
very interesting to see if they're Trump.
Also slams Pence and what the crowd reaction
would be is something I would want to see
as well.